the signs we've been having in the last  few months so actually the things are  improving the recovery is continuing  it's slow but it's stronger and broader  than in the past it's now it's now  taking place also in so-called formerly  called stress the country's non-core  countries and it's driven by consumption  and of recent also by investment and  that's another positive sign on the  migrants it's quite clear what's  happening will is changing and will  change deeply the social texture of the  European Union I should say that the  sale of banks was an entirely national  decision ECB had no role decision-making  role in the sale of these banks about  being accountable to the Parliament we  are accountable to the European  Parliament no no not to the national  parliaments that's why I'm here and I'm  responding to your questions  you